we're going to begin with a bombshell
report apparently revealing a sharp
discrepancy between the president's
Public Image and his private practices
in business here in New York the New
York Times has obtained data from the
tax records that he spent years trying
to conceal he shows it shows rather that
he's paid almost no federal income taxes
recently just
$750 in 2016 and 2017 and nothing at all
in 10 out of the 15 years before that
the data also shows he claimed May
losses on his businesses even as he
publicly said they were thriving and
that he may be under severe Financial
pressure in the next few years with
hundreds of millions in loans reportedly
set to come due the president is
forcefully denying the Times report
which CBS News has not verified Paula
Reid is at the White House Paula these
are some pretty extraordinary findings
good Morning Anthony these are some
extraordinary findings because they tell
a very different story about the
president and his business organizations
than the one he has sold to the American
public over decades according to these
new documents in 10 of the previous 15
years the president paid no income tax
largely because his businesses reported
losing much more money than they
actually
earned president Trump in a press
conference Sunday denied a New York
Times report that claims he only paid
$750 in income tax in 2016 and 2017 it's
totally fake News Made Up fake we went
through the same stories you could have
asked me the same questions four years
ago I had to litigate this and talk
about it uh totally fake news but when
asked directly how much he did pay Mr
Trump continued to tease the eventual
release of his long-sought tax returns I
look forward to releasing that I look
forward to releasing many things I'm
going to release many things and people
will be really shocked the New York
Times obtained tax return data extending
over more than two decades and found Mr
Trump paid lower taxes using
questionable tactics including a 72.9
million refund that is currently being
audited by the IRS while claiming losses
for many of his namesake businesses
including his golf courses Mr Trump has
maintained a lavish Lifestyle by taking
tax deductions on what some people would
consider personal expenses including
housing aircraft and $70,000 in hair
styling for tele appearances even though
president Trump vowed to no longer
pursue any new business once elected
according to the New York Times he made
$73 million from foreign deals during
his first two years in the White House
in a statement to CBS News Alan garton
an attorney for the Trump organization
said the New York Times story is riddled
with gross inaccuracies over the past
decade the president has paid tens of
millions of dollars in personal taxes to
the federal government he also said said
the times rejected our repeated request
that they show us any of the
documentation though the paper says it
declined to provide records in order to
protect its sources the president has
long refused to release his tax returns
the first president in modern history
not to do so I will release my tax
returns against my lawyer's wishes when
she releases her
33,000 emails that have been deleted as
soon as she releases them I will release
I will release my tax returns and has
frequently made this argument against
releasing them they're under audit and
when they're not I would be proud to
show however an audit does not prevent
the president from releasing his records
Democrats seized on the new reports
minority leader Chuck Schumer tweeted
raise your hand if you paid more in
federal income tax than president Trump
these new records suggest that the
financial pressures on President Trump
are mounting as hundreds of millions of
dollars in loans he personally
guaranteed are coming due now usually
excessive debt is seen as a potential
National Security vulnerability for
public servants because it could open
you up potentially to outside influence
now in addition to that IRS audit the
president and his justice department
continue to fight subpoenas by New York
State seeking other tax records and
financial documents all of which could
potentially open the president up to
criminal liability Tony Paul I would
also remind people that federal income
tax in particular pays for the military
the FBI border patrol farm programs
veterans benefits student benefits on
employment it touches really all of us
Paul thank you very much